i hate hearing these stories of
girls getting taken advantage of
it's basically all it is is mastermind
manipulation
yeah they find your weakness and they
use it against you you know they use
your emotions
you know i'm saying uh so what gets
women into these relationships with
i mean they're not really pimps they're
more gang members that are just
realizing they can they can
exploit what girls are doing on the
street it's not even gang members it's
just
men i feel maybe who had
past experience with women mommy issues
you know or something and
but now they're functioning they're
functioning like pimps because they're
taking the money that you guys make yeah
but they don't call themselves pimps
but they use the pimp mentality
in order to get what it is that they
want you know
they're not there it's not like they
have holes on the corners and you know
riding around like how
what pimps usually do you know they can
just be
regular guys manipulating women
womenizing
to get what it is they want you know
regardless if they use
regards if they use sex or
money not money sex or um or uh
love
is basically anything that draws a woman
to a man to lure you in
to lure you in and then once you're kind
of attacking once they know that they
have you
they they'll test you they'll do little
things to see you know i'm saying how
you'll react
and once they see that you're they're
getting the reaction that they want or
you're
you're responding there where they want
they know they got you
you know and and a person can only do to
you what you allow them
right so if you keep allowing it they're
gonna keep doing it but it just gets
worse and worse
but there seems to be a lot of the young
girls that are
victims of this yeah getting taken
advantage of
and they let it go on and they're hoping
for something better but it's never
gonna happen and it never happens
it never does this is definition of
sanity doing the same thing over and
over
maybe with different people yeah but
always expecting different results and
it was also always the same maybe some
of the ladies will watch these videos
and figure it out
yeah because i mean
the logic in knowing and comprehending
what's going on
or what somebody's doing to you and
still
doing the same thing or allowing it to
happen it's insane
and then they'll they'll get the girls
addicted to meth or crack or whatever
because that's that's what happened to
me you know i was in a relationship
but at the time with a female you know
um i was a dancer
she used to work for the refinery lost
her job for whatever reason
i told her okay don't worry about
nothing i got it i paid the bills
i took care of her her daughter you know
and it got to a point where i didn't
know she was using drugs
but she told me um
one day she was like i need some more
money and it's like how do you need some
more money i just gave you
five hundred dollars you know i'm saying
sometimes i'll give her seven
it depends on how good i do you know i
didn't have any with her but i gave her
something
and it's like where's your money going
you don't have to pay for nothing so
what are you doing
i said and i told her i said your money
that the money i give you is your money
what's in my pockets is mine you can't
control or dictate none of that i don't
have to give you nothing but what i want
to give you
and that's what triggered it so she got
me started on drugs and she used
love she played on my emotions you know
i'm saying my trust
for her in order to get me to do it
because you would never think somebody
who loves you
or cares about you will sit here and
bring such a
demonic demon into your life
but she did and i know this because
years later she admitted it to me
because i actually like why did you do
this and she told me just like how i
said it is exactly what she told me
it pissed her off
at some point living this lifestyle
where everyone's taking advantage of
everybody and it's just
you're disappointed on a daily basis
right
do you ever just like go
what the [ __ ] let me get out of here
every day but you but what stops you
from doing it
because you've been doing it for how
long now for too long
yeah for way too long like a lot a lot
of people would watch this video and go
like just get out
i see it in the comments it's not that
easy just say hey okay i'm gonna get out
if it was that easy you know i'm saying
people would do it it's easier said than
done yeah
it's hard because where you're gonna do
how you support yourself it's not even
about
it's not even about supporting yourself
it's the mental damage
the emotional damage the spiritual
damage
you know that that [ __ ] weighs on you
yeah because your self-worth gets beaten
down by living this life right
all the way down you feel broken inside
yeah
and all this pain and hurt that's inside
you it's like every day
you try to numb it that's what i think a
lot of people don't understand is how
destructive this lifestyle is to your
psyche to your
software it is it is and every day it
gets worse and worse and you guys might
look beautiful you're dressed nicely and
you're certainly very attractive but
your self-worth is in the gutter
and you're doing these things and giving
all the money to some stranger
or some guy that's lying to you and
cheating and doing everything
and you put up with it whereas most
people be like no just just do the right
thing and get out
but you're you're so broken that you
can't is that it right and it's
certain things that they do they keep
you trapped something they keep opening
hold over your head you know and then
it's like
the mental just
manipulation you know because they make
you feel like it's your fault
you know they twist things to make it
feel like it's you it's you
it's you you know and then that makes
you want to run to the drugs because
you're trying to numb it you're trying
to get away
because that's the only thing that gets
you out your head
and i know it sounds crazy or it sounds
like an excuse but it's it's a reality
how many of the girls are addicted to
crack or meth down there
100 i've never met anybody who wasn't
right that's a
that's the answer i mean even there's
people outside this lifestyle
they tell me they used to but the truth
is they they also
and it's like everybody has an addiction
drugs
money shopping um gambling
coffee cigarettes you know
everybody has an addiction so nobody's
really
any better than anybody else because
it's not about what they're addicted to
it's
the feeling or the mental of being
addicted
just like it's hard for some people to
stop drinking or stop smoking cigarettes
or you know i'm saying with coffee some
people can't even function in the
morning unless they have their coffee
don't talk to me i haven't had my coffee
you know
so it's
it's hard you know
some things are easier to deal with some
things affect you differently
like coffee or cigarettes it's not gonna
you know um
cause you to go through things that most
other people go to go through addicted
to other things you know
but in a way they're everything it's all
destructive yeah i'm thinking smoking
cigarettes can
you know what i'm saying is bad for your
health coffee is bad for you
all this stuff is bad for you i'm hoping
that enough if enough women watch my
prostitute and pimp videos they'll
eventually figure out
how much of a trap this life is it is
it's a trap and sometimes you get
trapped without even knowing
no you're you're you're walking into it
going this this feels good
especially if you're not from
the environment where it's created or
where it's at
like i i'm not from la you know
so when i came like i said when i came
out here it was like a movie like oh my
gosh
like boys in the hood or something like
that more so it's this
excitement because it always looks shiny
in the beginning
you know i'm not saying the prostitution
part all that that comes later on you
know
but you meet certain people and you know
they seem a certain way you're like oh
okay you know
and that comes from batch uh bad
judgment and character
you know did you tell me about your your
father
my dad um he was a good man
he was um the first black man to make it
to nationals in it in the nhra
you know yeah so so your dad was a good
stand-up guy
yeah he yeah my dad left the legends he
had a good
father figure yeah but he wasn't
he was there physically but emotionally
um he wasn't
you know financially he was but as far
as being able to
teach me and groom me to know what type
of man
i'm supposed to be with or what i should
allow it and not allow i didn't get that
i lacked that the love the affection you
know i lacked that
so as i got older i was looking for that
but the places i was looking for it was
all the wrong places
you know and when people learn your
weaknesses or what
what it is that you lack or what it is
you know
that you like or what is you want
they use that against you you know
and are any of these
women saving money with their pimps are
they doing what yeah they're making a
lot of money they claim to be making a
thousand a night or whatever
are any of them actually saving money
some do
i had a i had a homegirl that she was
putting a little bit you know saying to
the side
you know and it was the same thing she
was in a relationship she met her dude
he was
her chick you know before
and they got a relationship and then he
turned into
this pimp you know or whatever
and i used to watch like they would he
would start an argument with her you
know if he didn't have anything any
drugs or money
he would just just start an argument out
of nowhere and just start talking are
you doing this
or you have some guy in the house you
[ __ ] there's all kinds of [ __ ] just you
know
just to get under her skin just to make
her want to chase
what it is to medicate and to numb
the [ __ ] was she but she was saving
money she was
you know but it took a long time for her
to break that cycle
you know it took a while she was the
bread winner
she was paying the bills and all that
but he would throw this is my place and
this then the other
and blah blah blah but it's like hey
it's your place but who's keeping it but
99 percent of them seem to be
who's keeping it you know nowhere yeah
like who's keeping
it going who's keeping you in this place
only thing you got going is your name
on the lease that's it yeah some do and
some don't i used to make that amount
when i was dancing you know um or when i
was working for the post office but now
it's it's not the same you know
especially with the day-to-day life
and the [ __ ] you have to deal with but
it's like making and having those two
different things
you might make it but what do you have
but it seems like
the girls get into a weaker
mental state after doing this for a
while than they were when they entered
it
because someone didn't internet enter it
willingly yeah they were interested
blindly like me
you know i entered it in a relationship
you know and then it just started
turning into something else
you know and it's like once you have
feelings like i'm a libra and libras
love hard
so once
i got you know i'm saying my feelings
got involved it's like things slowly
started unraveling
you know like things were getting
revealed and it's like
i got caught up
i didn't know what i was doing until it
was either already done or
yeah i was already in it and now you're
using crack nah he's going yeah cocaine
i smoke weed
you know i'm not i'm not a big drinker
but yeah
and this is not something that i ever
thought i would do
and it's crazy because i didn't start
dating men i stopped dating men at the
age of 17. i started back at the age of
31.
you know i dealt with women all majority
of my life so
me not knowing really how to deal with a
man and handle them
yeah so when they get aggressive it's
like i don't know how to
handle that aggressiveness i'm not going
to sit here and fight a man i have two
broke fingers from that
you know this one i have to get uh they
have to break it
and put it back in place this one just
was recently you know
and it's just crazy
yeah my baby daddy um the more i learn
about this life
and what goes on the more horrified i
get yeah
and it's like i try to do other things
like i used to i sell drugs i used to
boost
i used to um [ __ ] uh
not saying sell women but if somebody
came to me
and wanted something i knew where to go
you know i'm saying i was i was you know
saying the plug basically they used to
say
i can plug you to where you need what
you want or what you need or where you
need to go
you know so i i did it all you know i'm
saying jack of all trades
but it's like after a while it gets
tiring you know because what
what what do i have to show from it
besides
mental abuse physical abuse spiritual
you know i'm saying damage like what do
i have to show for it
some people win you know some people
lose
and some people just stay in the middle
stagnate what do you think would help
you get out now
you're so young
um
i don't say a divine intervention but um
a spiritual breakthrough because that's
where it starts at
is the spirit and it works its way up
once your spirit's strong
your mind becomes strong it seems like
you know i've heard a lot of the pimps
say it's it's all about mind control
what they do is they break your
spirit yeah and then you're defenseless
you're gonna do whatever they want for
as long because especially once you
become
so dependent on them because in the
beginning they did everything for you
in a regular relationship you know you
guys go out on days they pay for this
they buy you clothes
you know whatever it is you need they
whine and dying you
give you shell whatever it is
then all of a sudden it's all it said it
becomes
a struggle you know or how we're going
to do this
i'm saying how are we going to get this
how are we going to google so then the
woman
you know being the backbone okay baby um
i'm gonna try to
do this i'm gonna try to do that you
know and then that's how it gets the
ball gets started
and it's [ __ ] up and it's like a lot
of the women who
enter this you know like me i was
molested at the age of nine by my cousin
you know i was molested at the age of
nine by my cousin cousin
yeah um and it was
ongoing for a while even as i got older
they would try to make passes at me you
know
but being older you know i was able to
be more defensive to you know okay like
you know it's not cool but as a child
you know
you're trusting especially a family
member you know
women trust in men to protect them so
i'm thinking that this man who's my
family member
wouldn't do nothing to harm me
and how he is is that manipulation
and it's [ __ ] up
it's [ __ ] up women you know men want
to be treated as kings
but as a king you should treat me as a
queen but when you treat me as a peasant
you know i'll do pleasant things and
it's just it's it's crazy the way it is
it's like it's like these girls get
brainwashed
it's brainwashed and people will be like
are past judgments so quick you can't
pass judgment on nothing that you have
not went through
felt experienced or endured
if you haven't walked in my shoes you
can't say nothing to me you cannot judge
me
the only thing you can do is feel for me
other than that
your opinion is it's
it's it has no me it means nothing to me
because how that's like if somebody's
mother passed
and i say oh i understand i'm sorry
you know i'm saying i feel how can you
understand what i'm going through and
you never went through it
your mother's still alive so how can you
tell me you understand what i'm going
through and you never felt it
how can you sit here and tell me oh i
need to do this than the other
and you've never done what i've done how
can you advise me on something that you
can't
even understand
so until you walked the path i walked
you know it's like you can't you can't
you can't judge me i'm a person who can
judge me first of all it's god
and clearly nobody's a god so
until you've done that just you know
if you can't motivate or be inspiring or
helping you know just stay away
keep your comments to yourself
because you don't know me you don't know
my story we're all books
we're all books people judge the covers
of the books
without even getting the chance to read
the story
but if you want to know me to be able to
judge me or understand me read my story
in order for you to read my story you
have to listen
understand comprehend
take heave to what it is i'm showing you
telling you
or where i'm presenting you
because you can read a person you can
understand a person but you have to
pay attention
don't judge me off of what you see
judge me off of what you hear from me
what you exp
what you see from me
but see there's fictional books and
there's
and there's facts some people you know
will give you a fictional story
you know and there's some people who who
give you the facts
so sometimes it is hard to know who a
person is
or who they are or where their uh
what type of character they are because
they'll play a role
they'll put a facade you know for you to
see them the way they want you to see
them
or for you to
fall into whatever the lies or whatever
is
you don't say the motive they have on
even
you know displaying this false character
i take people's face value because
who are you who am i for you to lie to
me show me who you are
and i'll show you who i am and at that
point we can decipher if
we want to deal with each other that
doesn't have to be in relationships to
anybody
i don't have time to sit here and and be
tom dick harry larry mary sarah whoever
for me to gain anything from you because
that's too much to keep up with
accept me for who i am or don't accept
me at all
and i'm fine with that but this is me
either you accept what i've been through
what i'm going through and where i'm at
and where i want to be and if you can't
help me get from
where i'm at to where i want to be then
you're not for me
people always think that if they can
show something materialistic that that
some people fall for that they want the
materialist i don't care nothing about
that
because all that [ __ ] can be replaced
you can burn a hundred dollar bill and
you'd be given another one a regular
same one
this building can burn down they can
build another one your car can you know
sing
uh blow up and you get the exact same
goddamn car same year same color same
everything
but once i'm gone you're gone and
whoever's gone
i'll never be replaced i'm gone
so i care about love honesty respect
loyalty trust
and to be genuine with it that's what i
want
and see people take advantage of that
they don't try to sit here and lure me
in with materialistic things
they try to lure me in with
a person
that they know they can never be or that
they're not
but by playing the role they know they
can get what it is they want
and it sucks
all right trina thank you for the
interesting conversation
thank you i hope it helps somebody you
know i think it might
hopefully these videos help yeah young
girls figure out what's what's up and
what's not
yeah you know because
you got to love yourself you know
you got to know yourself you got to know
your self-worth and
especially after you have lost that or
lost sight of that it's hard to get it
back
but if you want better for you you have
to
because that's the page i'm on i have to
want better for me because if i don't
want better i won't have better
if i want the same same thing i'll be
stagnated where i'm at
and with what i'm getting in the
environment that i'm in
so the change comes within us
if we don't make a change it won't
nothing change
you gotta change people places and
things
awesome thank you great
thank you it was amazing thank you that
was such a nice surprise
you